and my number one advice to people is
don't quit your day job
while you're chasing dreams you can't
find your passion without going and
having experiences
i fail every single day at heart
attack the impossible brought to you by
evan and the iron cowboy
and there he is how you doing man
good brother what's up i love it so
ladies and gentlemen if you don't know
this is
uh james the iron cowboy uh
claimed the famous doing his 50 iron
mans in 50 days
50 states set a new world record for
that and now we've been trying to
organize this
a little bit back and forth and it's
finally great to have make it happen
dude
yeah we've uh i think we're both pretty
busy dudes
and uh and then obviously 2020 has been
insane
and so uh to try to put this together is
is awesome and i'm
stoked to be here on your platform uh on
your time
i'm just giving you a little bit of mind
and just happy to be part of it brother
i love it man now where are you you're
looking you're looking cold you got the
jacket on
where are you at right now i live in i
live in utah
uh so just base of the rocky mountains
um
i'm actually in my gym um at my house
and we keep it we keep it a little
little cool
um you know 60 60 degrees
um and i just love being comfortable i
love hoodies
um so yeah i love it dude well i'm in
toronto canada
and uh i keep my office at 55.
yeah just that because that's i grew up
in canada
um and so i am well aware of the harsh
winters i grew up on the west
um in calgary but uh yeah those
it's crazy because i i delivered uh
papers uh for the calgary herald as a
kid all right and
i i kind of i i've been blessed to go
around the world and do speaking
and i got asked the question once you
know
is is mental toughness are you born with
it or is it something that you cultivate
and uh and my answer was it was
cultivate and then they said okay so
where did your mental journey start
and uh so i thought way back and i was
like man you know what to be honest with
you it started
um i used to my dad um helped us as kids
earn money
and it started with shoveling the city
walks
for abandoned homes
in calgary and then i also at a really
young age got a paper
paper route and just slugging through
the snow um at 3 30 in the morning in
the freezing cold winters
i remember around christmas time my mom
would always have this jar of like hard
candies
and i would i would take as much as i
could and put it in my winter jacket
and uh and go out and deliver papers and
uh
just freezing cold but those candies
was a sense of home and warmth for me
and so i think you know what my mental
toughness journey started
under 10 years old just slugging through
the brutal winters
canadian winters uh just hucking papers
man
i love it dude i love it calgary calgary
winters are no joke for anybody watching
uh what i love about your story you know
you've got your mom who's the dreamer
visionary
all sorts of crazy ideas of what is
possible and what could happen
and just inspired but then could never
kind of
make anything happen yeah and then your
dad just like
blue collar hard workers show up get it
done no excuses go and do it
and and you kind of you're in the middle
you kind of figured out
how to do it where a lot of
entrepreneurs they they lent they land
on
your mother's side they can't figure it
out which one was harder for you to
learn like did you lean to one more
naturally and then the other one became
work
yeah uh first happy birthday to my dad
um it's his birthday today
no chance he's watching this so that was
kind of pointless
hey you never know what could happen
maybe it could happen i don't know maybe
i'm going to get a message
that he's he's watching um you know
i i land way way on the on the mom's
side of stuff
um you know school is really hard for me
total dreamer
uh in the clouds all the time really
hard to concentrate
um but you know just really with my dad
just drove home hard work and
i you know deep down inside i think he
has an entrepreneurial spirit because he
he helped us get that job with the city
to to shovel walks as an independent
contractor
um he was you know pushing us to go
raise money and
um i i worked at a you know in junior
high
uh i remember riding my bike to the uh
to like the department store and after
school i
pieced together the bikes that they
would sell on the floor and it was piece
work
and so you know deep down i think my dad
is an entrepreneur but he just
is just a hard-nosed worker and just
your traditional like
i don't feel pain i'm numb i could
literally get in the truck right now and
drive across the country by myself i
don't care
um kind of stuff and so i adapted a lot
of that
but but i resonated with the freedom and
dreaming
and that part of it and i didn't you
know i do watch people that
um just continually try to plan and
dream and they never
turn it into anything and then my dad
who's just a hard worker and just
grinds himself and and it's almost like
i watched him go through depression
and all of these things where he just
wasn't happy but he just like
all he knew was how to work and i was
like okay well i don't
i don't want to not be successful with
my dreams
and i also don't want to like just nose
to the grind work all the time
not a lot of fun you know kind of those
two
paradoxes and i was like there's got to
be somewhere right in the middle
where where i can can live and
and take that hard work and the dream
side of it and make it work
and it's it's been fun to to kind of
make that happen and you know as an
entrepreneur it
it doesn't happen overnight and my
number one advice to people is don't
quit your day job
while you're chasing dreams like put
food on the table if you've got a family
you've got to support those people
and you chase your dreams at the other
end of things um until your dream
now becomes your reality and uh and that
that's always a struggle too and people
don't like the answer they don't quit
your day job
because they're like no man i'm going
all in i'm i'm i'm doing it
and then i'm like okay that's cool but
be ready to to live out of your car
and and eat you know ramen um
you know kind of thing and it's
interesting um
uh everybody everybody you know
the buzz what's your passion find your
passion what's your what's your reason
why why are you doing this
uh and two things you you can't find
your passion without going and having
experiences
you're not gonna you're not gonna
realize what your passion is until you
go do it so go do as much stuff as you
can
what i love about your message is it's
it's
transcended just sports you know i mean
i guess maybe that was early days that
people are watching like oh like that's
possible it's doable but
what i love about it is people will
follow you or watch you even if they
have
no intention of ever running an iron man
or being an endurance athlete or any of
it but
they get inspired by your store and then
they go start a business or they go
like whatever their version of their
dreams are your hustle has kind of
transcended just the athletic world
and gone into the human world
well i i think i think you nailed it
right on the head i mean we have gone
outside
uh triathlon um and we're now speaking
to the human spirit
and and our story of sacrifice and
commitment
has given and taking risks right
has has given people the courage in
their own lives
and it's always interesting because you
never know the true
impact that you're having but there's
always somebody watching right whether
it's
one person or in your case millions of
people
um we all have our own little silent
audience
and i try to raise my kids to be the
just the shining light and best example
they can because we truly have no idea
who is watching and it's always
extremely humbling for me
to you know because there's there's
always those people in the shadows
who don't have the courage to come say
anything to you and they're embarrassed
of where they are
in their lives currently they want to be
more they're striving for excellence but
they're stuck
right as humans for some reason we get
stuck in our own heads in our own
thought process
we beat ourselves up ultimately we're
our toughest critic right
and so it's always crazy for me to and
our team to get messages to where it's
like hey you don't know me
uh but you've given me the courage your
family's example
um of the way you guys live and
persevere and attack the impossible
has given me the courage to to get out
of this abusive relationship or to
overcome drug addiction or to
to believe in myself and and that that's
that's one of the biggest reasons why we
show up on a consistent basis because
we don't know who's watching and we
truly don't know the the ripple effect
that we're having on
on people's lives on on the daily right
is is attack the impossible part of your
branding yet
no i think that's it that's a that's a
hat that's a t-shirt that's great dude
i i'm i man i'm terrible at branding me
you just did it what do you mean you
just did it attacked the impossible
that's awesome
okay people would people would buy that
hat people would buy that water bottle
or buy that buy that shirt and it's not
just about the
you know the merch sales and stuff but
it's okay let's let's partner on this
attack impossible brought to you by evan
and the iron cowboy
let's go dude i mean because when people
put it on they they feel like somebody
could wear that shirt
and then go to their job interview yeah
so our
the the book that we wrote that's on uh
audible and on prime
um is redefine impossible and
uh and it's because people people
in life that i've experienced that they
they
they set their benchmark compared to
what
is around them and and they look around
in society and go okay that's what i
want to achieve
and that instantly limits yourself to
what's truly possible because
our baseline is a society of mediocrity
and and you should use people's
accomplishments as
inspiration and kickstarters but then
set your own limits
and redefine what's possible for
you the individual and stops putting
limits on yourself based on
what current society is doing because in
my opinion society is getting soft and
moving backwards
and and we're not striving and pushing
the envelope of what's possible
and so i like to use other people as
benchmarks as what's possible
break through those barriers and then
set new limits and anytime i go and set
out to do anything
i'm not trying to reach someone else's
standard of excellence i'm trying to set
a bar
for for the future so that somebody else
can now believe
in what we did and go set their own uh
bar
of what's impossible and so i i love
that
we have in the past redefined impossible
and and my my current mission is to go
defy logic
um and if and if we can if we can show
up every single day and try to defy
logic then then we're never going to
miss the mark
and you're going to surpass anybody that
is out there trying to be excellent
and you're not limiting yourself with
self-beliefs and what other people
perceive as possible
right does that make sense yeah dude i
love it dude it's like
sometimes when you when you're talking
you get into this rhythmic flow
it's almost like spoken word rap it's
like i'm waiting for the waiting for the
james lawrence
yeah it's like it's just how you do
like how you default to acting when you
when you hit a certain rhythm it's like
it's just coming out it's great
i love it i love it um now you're a
youtuber too now which is exciting
starting to see the message i get out
there i just started so we
we haven't announced what it is but um
we i started the youtube channel a
hundred days out from
our next defy logic project
um and and we're currently sitting on
either 89 or 90 days out
and we're trying to we're trying to
release two episodes a week and really
because it's been interesting i've been
on this journey for 15 years and
it's not how i make my money it's just a
passion i have um
yeah i you know there's no money in
endurance sports trust me if you're
trying to make money do not go down this
road
um you have to do it because you love it
and and you hope to inspire some people
um so you know we we're 100 days out we
just started the youtube channel
no idea what we're doing but but what
happens has happened in the past is
people
see a headline right they see oh 50 iron
man's 50 days 50 states
that dude right there is genetically
gifted he's different than
everybody else and and they don't
realize that a decade worth of
of blood sweat tears and sacrifice went
into creating that headline
and and i mean i've been genetically
tested i've done i mean
trust me i'm an average white canadian
dude that has very little talent
i mean i i just choose to show up every
single day with relentless pursuit
and and so for me um i want to open up
the doors to
we got a we got a family i got five kids
uh this week i'm celebrating 20 years of
unbelievable marriage
um my house has four teenage girls in it
right now and we're trying to defy logic
and i want to open up the
the behind the scenes that look what
does it take to create a headline
because everybody out there in instagram
world is like oh dude i want that i want
what that guy has right
and you're like dude you you're not
willing to do what it takes
because here's the thing like everybody
knows what they want new years is coming
around the corner guys
and everybody's gonna be okay man this
is my year 2021 2020 sucked
i i know i want the bigger house i want
to i want more money in my bank account
i want to
i want to make it rain on a regular
basis i want a better relationship i'm
going to make babies you know all these
things
and and then you sit down and you say
okay
what's that going to take what does that
look like
and then you start to create the game
plan and you look and you go
oh i didn't realize that that's what it
takes to
to hit a level of greatness that is
beyond comprehension
i'm out and so everybody knows what they
want
but do you truly know at the highest
level know what you're willing to
sacrifice
and the moment you identify what you're
willing to sacrifice only then can you
start taking steps and strides to
getting what you want
and i promise you today's day and age
and people in society we live in a very
comfortable environment
despite all of the tragedy and the the
difficultness and the adversity that
we've experienced
we still live in an unbelievable place
like wake up like we is
this is the 20th century and we live in
an unbelievable place
start to know and identify what you're
willing to sacrifice
that's how you're going to get closer to
what you want in your life
show up every day with relentless
pursuit is that another way is that i
like it
he's just doing it so we just need to
make all of these shirts happen dude
i need i need a guy like you to just be
like okay that one's good
uh we're gonna do that one and then like
the team behind the scenes is just like
it's on the printer we're going let's go
yeah that's it you also need like
honestly as you're talking it's like i'm
already i'm already hearing a beat
behind the words as your as
your yeah yeah for sure i love it dude
now what i love about you too is um
this kind of softer side and not soft
like
mental toughness side but just you're
very relatable
you know it's like you're a normal dude
humble
hard-working where um you'd expect
someone like you to be crazy
i mean and you kind of are crazy in one
sense but but
when you look at um like a goggins right
who's also
crazy doing all sorts of endurance
things
uh he's an intense beast you know when
you get into an interview with him it's
like
it may not always connect with a lot of
people where you just seem like
a normal average dude yeah i really
appreciate that um i
i am i know i mean i'm middle america as
as they get i mean five kids
um trying to trying to be an
entrepreneur and we used to own a
mortgage company we lost everything
i trust me i remember the day they
knocked on my door and took away my home
and left me with nothing um and and we
had to rebuild
um i i'm not six six seven
six eight two hundred and forty five
pound lebron james who
obviously is a genetic freak and figured
out how
how to put in the work ethic and and put
an amazing team around him
i'm not a michael phelps that is
genetically built to swim like a machine
dude i'm i'm five eight pale white uh
i can grow a beard i think that's it um
and i've just figured out how to how to
do that and so i
i i appreciate the fact that you said i
i'm relatable because
i am a family man i i do struggle i wake
up people just assume oh man you
you love to get up and crush your
workout every day no i wake up every day
and come up with excuses of why not to
work out like that that's
i mean i mean every single day is a
struggle i get in my own way
it despite the things that we've
accomplished uh i have to find
motivation inside myself i draw
motivation from other people
i fail every single day hard
and and and look at that as an
opportunity to learn and grow so that i
can
come on the other side of that a
different person
um i'm i'm an introvert by nature i mean
in order to do
what we did you you have to be somewhat
an introvert and be okay with sitting
by yourself with your own thoughts
having those conversations with yourself
um over the past you know five years
i've spoken to 48 countries
and been on every every imaginable stage
that was me
intentionally becoming uncomfortable and
trying to do
the next version of what's hard right
like that was that was uncomfortable for
me
um i wake up with anxiety and fear and
i i battle with depression like
everybody else
and so um yeah it's just a constant
uh learning curve
of life where i i get up like everybody
else and put my
one foot in the pant leg just next foot
in the pant leg
brush my teeth like everybody else right
like try to not crack an eggshell in the
pan
dude i'd love to see more of that in
your 100 day
documentary yeah because if you're
me cracking an egg and a shell in the
eggplant well like
all of these stories because you could
say i put one paint on
you know like everybody else and that's
what everybody kind of says but
you're actually living it if you could
take people into the anxiety or the
nerves or the i don't want to work out
or like all the stuff that everybody can
relate to
because and i haven't watched all the
episodes but you know
it's the high-end stuff which is awesome
it's like you
fine-tuning this crazy superbike and all
the feedback and it's like it's a world
that most people don't have access to
it's just like
voyeurism or are you on the table with
the
you know world expert kind of working
your body and the crazy pain again like
somebody that most people are never
going to get
access to which is cool it's like a peek
inside that world but then to also
have you maybe you're afraid to be on
youtube
or maybe you're nobody's going to watch
the content or this 100 day challenge is
like scaring you to death or you woke up
and you don't want to go work
like that is cool man i think that's
something that you never get to see
yeah literally last night um i i i mean
just because of everything i put my body
through i've got some imbalances i grew
up as a wrestler i had shoulder surgery
um i'm almost 45 and so my body's not
what it once was i have to put a lot
more attention detail to those little
things
and i work with a mobility coach
virtually and i was doing a series of
exercises just last night in my gym
by myself um was
literally on the verge of tears um
because i was struggling
through some simple movements that as a
as an athlete at x level i should
shouldn't struggle with right
but that's the reality of where i am and
and where i need to get to
and and yeah just that constant everyday
struggle the conversation that i
sometimes lose in my own head right um
yeah that that's that's great content
dude like i want to see you trying to do
a
downward dog and then you're in tears
because it just hurts too much
right but then you're still doing it or
whatever the pose was right
well and i think i think it's hard too
because
you know you you get this perception
about you and you show up and everybody
say it's so funny like i'm five foot
eight right
and uh i'm not i'm not giant in stature
and i'll show up to an event and they're
like oh
man we thought you'd be bigger just
because of the
the perceived herculean feats that we've
accomplished and
and so it's like it's hard for me to get
to that vulnerable
space to where i can compose that
struggle
and i'm getting closer and closer to it
i mean
i mean for the past you know you come
off the 50 and you're four percent body
fat and you're just this shredded
marble you know god type cup
type physique and then you get thrusted
into this travel schedule and
i mean i was doing 80 events a year
globally and
i mean my race weight's 160 pounds and i
got up to 187
and i mean bmi scale that's that says
i'm
over overweight um for 5.8 to be almost
190 pounds
um so i was almost 30 pounds from
you know where i was and i developed
this like really bizarre case of body
dysmorphia
i remember less than a month removed
from the 50
i was so used to seeing this like
chiseled literally
25 pack right abs on abs
and success magazine came to my house
and they were like hey
we're gonna do uh this photo shoot and
shirt off it's gonna be spectacular and
i was like
i'm i'm not taking my my shirt off right
and i still had a six-pack and
everything but it was like
it wasn't what i believed the public
saw me as because of where we had gotten
to
and i didn't i didn't take my shirt off
for that photo shoot
and and i i was i was embarrassed as a
as a grown man
to to take my shirt off and get into
that vulnerable space
and even even today like i it's totally
sounds stupid and it's the issues that
we're dealing with in our own head but i
i won't really look at myself in the
mirror with my shirt off right now
uh because i don't have abs on top of my
abs right
and and it's just this this really
difficult
social whatever game that we play and
the perception that we have that other
people see us
as and so that you've created that right
like this is your
this is like is your greatest
opportunity because when i was doing a
little bit of research on you like hey i
got james on i should know a little bit
about what he's up to
um it only looks like the perfect stuff
and like
this guy is crazy endurance and you go
to the website go to instagram
and there's some fun moments of like
falling off the bike eating applesauce
and that kind of
camaraderie kind of stuff but but this
is like
you're still concerned about taking off
your shirt
and embarrass and don't want to do the
photo shoot like that kind of stuff
makes you everyday level
human which i think is actually your
superpower but then you still
show up that you're still super
frightened super nervous super afraid
but that's not a good enough reason to
not show up i'm still going to get to
the gym i'm still going to do my work as
i'm still going to chase down my goals
right like seeing that side
it's just it's all it is is a is
changing the intent of the content
instead of hiding behind it to put it up
front
and say hey i'm afraid to go work out
okay let's go work out
yeah i'm still it's interesting because
you know you have this persona and
people hold you at a certain esteem and
then it's like
okay i i need to develop the courage
in order to to really let people in and
that's that's scary and
it's the it's the reason why a lot of
people don't start on a journey
and because they are scared of what
other people think or the perceptions
that are out there
and i mean even again with everything
we've accomplished
it's still scary to show up in every
single day and
and and let people in right because
again i'm a i'm more of a private person
than i am anything else
um and and so yeah that's just that's
just where we're at today
you're hired as a producer by the way
welcome
welcome to the welcome to the team
fellow canadian there's a
we the north okay we're doing so we're
doing so we the north let's go
let's crank out some shirts and uh help
me with some some
production here i'm i'm super introvert
too it doesn't come across
in these kind of things but but super am
and i hear you like i've got a picture
of my parents that's me when i'm eight
or nine those are my parents above me
yeah i i tell like three stories about
my parents total
on social because they're super private
and and we have a great relationship
and they one of my greatest mentors of
all time but i just don't talk about
them because it makes them uncomfortable
if i tell stories about them even like
super positive ones
yeah so you don't have to let people
inside your life and know when your kids
birthdays are and what struggles they're
going through and all that stuff but
to know like you that you struggled with
going to the gym
or that you're nervous to do a photo
shoot or something and
the voice inside your head i think that
makes you
like even more superhuman than than the
persona that we see
yeah i i appreciate that and i'm getting
closer and closer i mean i hide behind
um this beard uh and and and
underneath hoodies right um it's it's my
security blanket right i feel safe
and uh all of these stories are that's
content man right like
that that's tomorrow's video but how you
hide behind a beard and hoodies
and a hat and it makes you feel safe
yeah
dude that'll be like if you really want
people to take over
like that 100 challenged we still don't
know what it is but at some point we're
going to figure out what it is
uh to make make them feel like their
journey is possible
i think that's it man it's like yes the
hard work and hustle and showing up but
also just the battling the
inner voices and demons and that you're
really just a
human who struggles with this stuff too
well and i think where i struggle too
is like i don't want this to turn into
like a
poor me pity show right like i
understand that
there needs to be a balance between like
feeling sorry for myself uh there is
certain struggle
and then the hero moments right there
needs to be a balance between all of
that and so i just
i'm just real conscious of like i don't
want to just turn into
it you'll never get there a poor niece
type story and
it'll never happen like you won't let
that happen that's not who you are
yeah it's just never going to happen
even if you tell your story
like ever all of the things you've
talked about here already are awesome
seeds for videos and stories
you'll just never let it get that way
because you don't feel sorry for
yourself
but you're still struggling with things
and and then you overcome when you go
and do it
yeah dude i'm pumped like that at least
just one about one of the next 20
youtube videos turn it into something
like
the hiding behind the don't want to just
see how it feels and see what the
reaction is i think it'll be your best
video
yet okay
and my beard's [ __ ] and so at the end
of the day
i still have that there you go so when
do we find out about what the 100
thing is when when's the drop date for
what the challenge actually is
yeah probably january 1st i need to get
through december
uh make sure i'm hitting some decent
benchmarks where i want to be
um either way the project's going
forward
yeah i just don't like to talk about one
thing for too long and so right now
we're just going to focus on
um kind of behind the scenes and then
when we're sick about 60 days out
then we'll start you know talking about
what we're doing and why we're doing it
there's a big cause behind what we're
doing love it man cool well
listen super appreciate the time today
for people they want to
connect with you or follow the journey
where we're going to link it up on the
description for youtube where do you
want them to go
instagram youtube channel i'd say right
here at iron cowboy james
and then you can link directly to our
youtube um
through the link in our bio so just
starting the youtube channel
uh we're going to get better we want to
get subscribers and likes and
um just really open up the door i'm
going to take evan's advice i'm gonna be
um as vulnerable um as as possible
without uh
dripping into the the pathetic zone you
won't drip in their pathetic time okay
listen i'll make you a trade i'll make
you a trade
okay here we go here's the trade uh make
make
one of those videos out of your 100 that
that explains a vulnerable story the
beard of the or the
hoodie or whatever and and uh in return
i will sit with your team and give them
some free
youtube coaching to help you blow up
your channel well here's
here's maybe the bad news on that deal
you're currently sitting with the team
okay great i'll sit with you after
and we'll break down give you some ideas
on how to make it better
i'm not i'm not big enough of a deal to
have a team and so i kind of
i kind of run run all of everything that
we do
which is probably why it's terrible it's
not terrible
there's lots there's lots of room for
for growth that's all
make the video and then i'll help you
with your channel we'll set up a private
call after this and i'll help you
give some ideas for your channel i i
appreciate that i know you're super busy
appreciate the time today
i just want to send a message of love to
everybody
be the kindest person you can because we
have no idea who's struggling
everybody puts on this uh hides behind a
beard and we call that social media
uh social media can be a place of
unbelievable um
exposure and and let's shift the
narrative to
instead of all the negativity and and
arguing and drama let's shift it to a
place of
of happiness thankfulness and gratitude
um if everybody made that their goal
can you imagine how infectious and
positive
a social media platform could be if we
were all just like vibin
off of just such amazing great things i
mean what a what a cool concept
nobody needs to take a fast from social
media they need to shift who they follow
they need to shift the content that they
put out and if somebody's triggering you
on social media
dude block that button man just push
that button get them out of your life
and start adding
joy and happiness to your life so each
one of us can
control our own social media feeds as
far as what we consume and what we put
out there
so that's that's my challenge just be
kind humans um
stop with all the negativity the banter
whatever it's okay for other people to
have a different opinion than you do
um and and just just be the the kindest
person you can be i want everybody to
have an unbelievable holiday
i want everybody to um be safe i want
everybody to make intelligent decisions
for yourself and not be driven
in in a state of fear and anxiety
all of that is 100 possible so evan
again thank you so much for having us on
i really appreciate you taking the time
i know how valuable your time is so
thank you and everybody have an
unbelievable holiday season thank you
i love it somebody clipped that and put
a beat behind it that's what i'm talking
about
iron cowboy james thank you man i'll
talk to you soon
alright man see you peace if you want to
see the one on one i did with
wim hof the iceman check it out right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there remember
deep breathing is able is able to change
the biochemistry
insight deeper than ever thought
possible